sentidos
[Música]
es normal en bandera
soldados rusos muy animados en mariupol
en el suroeste de ucrania es lo que
muestran los vídeos del canal the
telegraph guard gonzo hola a todos este
es el proyecto world gone shop nuestro
reportaje exclusivo sobre la liberación
de mariupol y los vídeos fueron grabados
por sergio aunque gob un antiguo
corresponsal de un canal de televisión
ruso en 2017 se convirtió en bloguero de
guerra y hoy cuenta con 800 mil
suscriptores en youtube y más de un
millón en telegrama como miembro de una
unidad militar pro rusa en la
autoproclamada república de donges
publica vídeos grabados cerca de los
combates
un discurso favorable al kremlin sobre
la guerra que a menudo roza la
desinformación esto es lo que nos
explicó jacques margolín que estudia los
conflictos en el centro de estudios
avanzados de defensa de eeuu
pero es periodista de formación
desde la invasión de ucrania en febrero
de 2022 se ha convertido claramente en
un propagandista ruso y ha empezado a
apoyar directamente a los implicados en
el conflicto
te felicito
hay una mezcla de reportajes auténticos
y certeros
así como de información completamente
inventada difunden el mismo mensaje de
que ucrania está llevando a cabo un
genocidio y que rusia ha venido a salvar
a esta gente que se trata de un esfuerzo
para como ellos dicen de clasificar a
ucrania
vamos a contarles algunos datos
interesantes sobre los crímenes de
guerra cometidos por el batallón a soft
y otros neonazis ucranianos
hay varios canales que son muy pro rusos
dirigidos por personas que están entre
el estatus de periodistas o combatientes
max info min la lenta tardes que empezó
como combatientes estuvo en el ejército
ruso paso por la cárcel luchó como
voluntario en el donbass y luego se
convirtió en una especie de periodista o
creador de contenidos
toda esta gente alcanzar indirectamente
una gran audiencia y esa es su verdadera
utilidad en la propaganda rusa en mi
opinión esto está causando armario
pública karlo boned se pre casas pulsión
astaná bisturí
gran parte de su contenido es reciclado
por los medios de comunicación estatales
rusos o es retomado por periodistas
extranjeros que pueden no entender el
contexto y por lo tanto son replicados
por todas estas razones hay que tener
mucho cuidado esta gente tergiversa
muchas cosas que están pasando pero
también son a veces una ventana útil a
cosas que uno no vería de otro modo
en los observadores de france 24
llevamos varios años documentando los
abusos de los cobros comunidades de
vigilantes integradas por civiles para
hacer frente a los problemas de
inseguridad en burkina faso el 20 de
marzo un lector al que llamaremos
jean-yves fue testigo del trato que
reciben las personas detenidas por los
pueblos en uagadugú las víctimas tenían
los pies atados con cadenas
janis grabó la escena nos la transmitió
y accedió a declarar sin mostrar su
rostro por motivos de seguridad
ver a personas a seres humanos
encadenados como si no fueran nada no
deja de ser impactante ni siquiera
tienen derecho a una comida durante el
día nadie les va a dar de comer si
tienen a alguien que les traiga comida
no hay problema pero si no tienen a
ningún familiar ni nada entonces se
morirán de hambre hay una parte del
vídeo en la que se ven baldes en el
suelo estos baldes son utilizados en
realidad para que los presos hagan sus
necesidades ya que no se les permite ir
al baño las personas estaban allá por
diversos motivos había algunos que
estaban allá por casos de robo casos de
malversación también vi a un niño que
estaba allá porque se había escapado de
su casa creo que no tenía ni 12 ni 14
años y también vi a un joven que estaba
allá porque tenía problemas con sus
hermanos con respecto a la herencia así
que querían acusarlo de cosas para poder
dejarlo sin herencia nos pusimos en
contacto con samir abdul karim de drago
que se presenta como ponente del jefe
del estado mayor de los pueblos
nos explicó que está justificado
inmovilizar a un individuo para que no
huya pero que hay que valorarlo en
función de su peligrosidad precisó que
los colobos sólo deben detener a los
ladrones oa las personas que van armadas
sin motivo en efecto desaprobó el
tratamiento dado a las personas en este
vídeo desde los primeros abusos
documentados por nuestra redacción en
2015 los cobros de ojos no han dejado de
estar activos en la capital de burkina
faso aunque son bastante populares entre
la población local sus abusos suelen ser
ignorados
hay que decir que antes no tenían ningún
problema con los cobros pero cuando fui
allá quedé impactado porque las
condiciones en que se trata la gente son
abominables estamos en un estado de
derecho las personas no pueden sustituir
a las instituciones estatales en estos
tiempos creo que no se debería permitir
que este tipo de prácticas continúen
el pasado mes de diciembre el ministro
de seguridad máximo con él celebró una
conferencia con los cobos y otros grupos
de iniciativas locales de seguridad
recordó la importancia de sus acciones
especialmente en la lucha contra el
terrorismo en las zonas rurales pero no
cuestionó los métodos de algunos grupos
como lobos
eso es todo en los observadores de esta
semana si quieren escribirle a nuestra
redacción pueden hacerlo por whatsapp
twitter y correo electrónico todos los
contactos aparecen en pantalla envíenos
sus fotos y videos y quizás el próximo
observador del france24 sea usted
gracias especiales a templo de nuestra
locación para la grabación de hoy hasta
pronto